Film Courage: "Art is something to live for. If you find
yourself comfortable enough you make
enough money and you live in the state
of finding inspiration and creation and
that is my definition of making it." Josh Yeo, Artist/Founder of MAKE.ART.NOW. Youtube Channel: Yeah.
Film Courage: Was this always your definition? Josh: Uh...no. My
first you know when I was eighteen
nineteen first moving out here I had one
of those vision boards remember those
were like the hip and I had a vision
board and I had like you know a Bentley
on it and had an Amex Black and it had
like a Breitling watch and you know or
whatever and I had models. Like it
was so so detached from like reality of
like what is what what is actually worth
living for is it things like things that
validate you I don't know if that's true
if you look at all the rich people that
are very miserable in life they would
argue that's just their very existence
isn't that's not true I think the people
that are that are happiest in life they
have a sense of purpose they have a
sense of value normally it's earned
value so there are rich people that have
earned value and they like Bill Gates
he's probably one of the happiest
wealthy wealthiest people in the planet
right now and look at him he's like
totally has all this valleys giving back
he's making toilets that like will work
in India that are they run on nothing
like solar-powered toilets or something
you're talking that guy isn't has nailed
it right so like we all can't be Bill
Gates but maybe we can all have that
sense of value and so for me it was like
you know creating art creating something
if it's maybe just a poem or a snapshot
or something that gives you a little bit
of inspiration if it if it affects you
if it's something that you remember for
years and you're like wow that really
inspired me or like that got me out of a
slump that's that's something to live
for
that's amazing I think I heard Steve
Wozniak say that he just really wanted
to make cool stuff all the time that was
his goal and he was in a position of
course to do that but that prompted you
know that you could see that behind
what they created and continued even
after I feel like people like Steve
Wozniak who have that mentality they
don't stop like they just keep like
they're so the moment for me was I you
know as an actor you always say I want
to make it right I want to I want to
make it and what does that mean oh it
means like you got all the roles you got
money in the bank you got a house paid
off
you got a vacation home yeah you got
nice family and your kids are going to
college normally just means success and
money right and then I was like and then
what like so if I'm envisioning this I
make it and then what and then I just
stop I just stop like if that if my
definition of making it is just things
and money eventually I'm gonna get that
and eventually I'm not gonna know what
to do with my time so that can't be the
goal the goal has to be something a
little bit loftier than that it has to
be something that it's it's dependent on
I don't know it's it's something that
you just keep doing right so like
inspiring people that would that's a
goal because that that has no end you
just keep doing that till the day you
die there's no so for making it for me
stop becoming monetary incentives and it
became let's just blow people's mind
let's that's yeah let's do that and just
keep doing that and keep doing it how do
i how do i do that you know so that's
what it is for me and that mental
challenge to that comes from well you
know what it was uh making it change
forms and instead of making it it was
making it right the process of making it
became make art now so that mental
challenge I think I have to deal with
every day of what am I gonna make today
what's gonna be new what's gonna be
different what's gonna what's gonna blow
my mind because if it blows my mind then
there's a good chance it might blow your
mind too do you go to the Getty [A museum in the Los Angeles area]
do you do like cultural things in LA
I've gone to the Getty several times
both villas and I've gone to LACMA [Los Angeles County Museum of Art] I think
what what really what I enjoy the most
what inspires me the most is attempting
something I've never done before it's
challenging and then once I get kind of
once I crack the code there's normally
like three things that you need to learn
to like start getting good results
there's only it's it's funny it's only
like three things like once you know the
code those three things you can get some
pretty good results right and so for me
it's always like trying set that new
thing figuring out those three things
and then looking at that footage and and
being like Wow holy moley. I did like
that's how they do it oh my goodness that
nobody tells you that like totally
reverse engineering it that's what gets
me going and I feel the most inspired
after that so it'll be like a night
shooting downtown LA middle of the
middle of like you know 2:00 in the
morning or something like that no one's
up and I'm rolling around on my one
wheel filming skyscrapers and my mind's
totally blown and I'm I'm so excited
that I can't go to sleep you know yeah
that's sorry last question just have you
ever had anything risky happen what do
you mean by risky well I mean you're
with camera equipment people are
probably drawn to you like what are you
doing are you an actor you hope I feel
yeah I have this I feel like every shoot
is kind of risky like I've hurt myself a
couple of times you know riding around
on a one wheel with camera equipment in
traffic like that's risky
like those normal people shouldn't take
those risks I'm totally fine and
comfortable taking those risks but I
also acknowledge that if that's the
requirement to be seen on YouTube that's
a very risky profession so but I feel
like I've always been the kind of
personality to try to get my hair blown
back you know
so it definitely satiates some part of
adventure in me
you